I want to do something fun okay so you
literally like eat a steak we're gonna
eat a steak no because you are you have
authored books on food it's all
corporate in your stand-up so I wanted
to get your input on some of the more
popular food drugs you got it okay I'm
ready
how do we feel about avocado toast well
you know I don't want to blame avocado
toast for Trump's election but no I
think avocado toast it's good but let's
let's not pretend that it's some kind of
artisanal thing you're taking an avocado
and putting it on toast right and it's
$15 yeah it's and and it's all right
the avocado it's weird avocado and
hummus it's almost like to white America
it didn't exist until 1980 obviously it
was always there but now we're just like
avocado this new vegetable I mean I love
avocados it's like it's like a vegetable
that wants to be a cheese sushi burritos
unnecessary Thomas as if are we that
bored I mean it's like sushi is fine
just like it is it's also great
we don't have to combine them yeah like
we're not that we're not in that kind of
hurry
are we no well who knows I guess we can
hand hold sushi that way yeah
cauliflower pizza if you can't have
bread or whatever and cauliflower works
and it's healthy that's fine but like
this need to like make something
appealing like cauliflower I feel this
way about Brussels sprouts too it's like
look Brussels sprouts
by the way invented in Brussels and
someone who's like how about like
miniature cabbages that are only good if
they're deep-fried and butter and bacon
you know but like I feel as though the
cauliflower thing it's just like I guess
for health reasons sure I don't like
food that pretends to be other food
right it would be what you are right
it's like Doritos that taste like pizza
just get pizza yeah right yeah just do
and just get the Doritos right that's
how the founding fathers wanted that
pumpkin spice lattes first of all let me
just say let me piss off a lot of people
great I think that we have to like all
the boutique coffee shops they're
working in a coffee shop they're around
caffeine we got to pick it up a little
bit they see people at their worst it's
like I just feel like there's a doorman
see like you go in there and they act
like they're an ICU nurse that's just
done two shifts it's like you're putting
first of all you're the barista you're
not a scientist
all right you're not a scientist this is
gonna piss out so many people but it's
like let's get going here let's get
going you're not a sushi chef you're
you're literally going and you're
pouring milk into a cup anyway I just
wanna piss house with coffee people
finally Kailyn general I think it's over
I think it's we're reaching the end
we're done with kale I think we're
almost at the point where we're gonna
find out that kale causes cancer right
because it always starts like it's great
it's like this thing that nobody eats
that we feed animals to just get them
fat so that we can eat their meat wait a
minute there might be some value in that
and then we figure out to make a way to
make it appealing and then we find out
it makes people infertile you know like
there's just this evolution yeah food I
I guess the message I'm trying to say is
just eat cheese just eat cheese just eat
cheese well Jim thank you so much for
coming in indulging me with your
responses we figured it all out now
we're gonna go eat sticks all right
thank you thank you thank you at
you